est ce qu'on a vu malik bentalha
entraîné qu'il y avait ma paie pour le
rendre plus performant en revanche été
mise très bien qu'il ya même pas p oui
enfin très bien je sais pas médiane
alors tu on sait que tu es un des plus
grands joueurs de tous les temps tu
vient d'égaler le record de yannick
stopyra la moitié ne parle pas d'âge
c'est la parole au président nasser
projet de bourdes et bourgogne et l'ex
champion mais qui diane labrosse
d'ailleurs assez incroyable ce qu'il
entraîne c'est le patine à gagner roland
garros dans deux ans ce qu'on a pu malik
bentalha reprendre du michael jackson à
la radio joue avec talent
ouais et vous allez voir que manning a
quasiment la même voie que michael
jackson
ces saisies sont fermés vous allez voir
michael jackson un ordre de retour en
bacs
je t'ai dit j'adore quand tu fait